Let's start with Medium.
As the page gets larger,
we can see that the text reflows.
That's good, but
that's not a breakpoint.
But, once the viewport is wide enough,
we see that the images got larger and,
so did the text.
That's a breakpoint.
Once the viewport is this wide,
we can see that there's now
a margin on this side of the page.
That is another break point, so
in the medium.com example I noticed two
break points in the men with max
width example we start off and
the page says no,
then it gets a little bit larger and
the page says yes, but
if we get to big it goes back to no.
So, this means that the course
example also has two break points.